question pour stone bryce qui a
participé à cette fête bah moi je pense
que ça fait vraiment du bien de sortir
parce que on est toujours à la maison on
travaille tout le temps là on s'est dit
bon il fait chaud on sort ça fait du
bien mais on en dit quoi vos parents ils
étaient pour il était content j'ai des
composites est d'accord ouais mais ta
grand mère
allez sortez sortez hama nord madame je
pose une question sahraouie parce que
oui parce que pour après c'est vrai non
mais c'est vrai que oui après forcément
pour le jeu testé une bonne et oui non
ni avant la fête ni après la fin je n'ai
jamais fait main adacore n'avait donc
c'est pas si vous êtes vous regrettez
aujourd'hui n'est pas du tout un petit
peu c'est vrai je mets un petit peu
parce que je me dis c'est bien mais
c'est contre parce que c'est bien on
sort tous ensemble on s'amuse et ses
comptes parce qu'on sait qu'il ya quand
même beaucoup de personnes qui sont ré
des nations alors de gestion et vous
avez craqué en a eu marre j'en avais
marre reste à la maison et 25 degrés à
lyon et c'est commencer tellement vous
êtes réunis secte et quoi l'histoire
c'est à dire on sait rémanents me mois
de bataille avec un pote on sortait sur
les quais on a bougé et on a vu un
attroupement de personnes et on s'est
dit pourquoi pas y aller c'est en france
et bim d'encre alors on va avoir la vie
de brice dans un instant et bruno bien
sûr un talent d'un autre policier
guillaume vous vous êtes d'accord avec
avec je suis d'accord et c'est lorsque
j'étais à lyon ce week-end
exactement à cet endroit là en fait ce
qui a changé la sépia de la musique
parce qu'à tout le monde sur les quais
même à paris personne les confiner les
gens sont dans la rue il ya de moins en
moins de gens qui portent le masque et
attention ne vous trompez pas c'est pas
la seule fête avec des jeux en ce moment
il ya plein de jeunes qui font la fête
locale à présent ils n'en peuvent plus
qui s est naïf pour croire franchement
que les jeunes là alors je parle pas au
nom de tous les jeunes sikhs en a qui
respecte les gestes mais sont confinés
sagement depuis un an et restent chez
eux tout seuls le soir bord dans des
petits studios mais attendez mais vous
vous rendez vous quoi bruno quand vous
entendez ça j'ai eu 20 ans aussi moi
aussi j'ai envie d'aller avec eux faire
la fête c'est pas de problème en soi
mais ils se rendent pas compte enfin son
jeu ils ont 20 ans ils sont jeunes et
ils se rendent pas compte que voilà par
exemple si les policiers devaient
intervenir à intervenir lamont
heureusement qu'ils sont pas intervenus
mais c'est dangereux des tombes et
collègues pour ces jeunes pour leurs
parents pour on va parler aussi
peut-être des infirmières on va parler
de demain aux gens qu'ils sont mais ils
ont 20 ans et voilà et moi j'ai pas
envie le truc contre les jeunes ce soir
je les comprends mais voilà moi je
fonctionnaires de police et voilà vous
on est dans un état républicain vous
commettez des infractions c'est
compliqué c'est compliqué de mettre des
amendes à des jeunes comme ça on y est
alors on n'y a pas été tout simplement
parce que il ya un vrai danger bon en
plus il ya la jurisprudence de nantes où
il ya une personne qui est tombée alors
on vend des contrats les gamins en plus
ça picole voilà j'ai pas envie d'être le
père fouettard et faire le dos rond et
leur dire c'est pas bien mais voilà moi
je fonctionnaires de police se joue à
mes collègues qui en peuvent plus qu'ils
sont crevés et et on voit ça enfin voilà
ça c'est dur à encaisser ça doit être
compliqué aussi pour vous de se dire
allez là dessus c'est compliqué de
réprimander des jeunes quand on se dit
voilà on se dit bon c'est vrai qui c'est
vrai qu'ils sont hors la loi en ce
moment mais c'est vrai qu'on se dit il
ils font rien de mal si on n'était pas
en période de de confinement et c'est
vrai que c'est compliqué d'aller quand
même ce que j'aime pas c'est quoi
hiérarchise hier ashes la douleur
c'étaient les jeunes souffrent ok mais
il ya beaucoup de gens qui souffrent
toujours dire que mes collègues
voilà on est on est au bord du gouffre
on est fatigué encore une fois je vais
parler des infirmières mais on souffre
tous donc là mais ils ont vingt ans
maintenant moi voilà je peux pas être
complaisant avec ça mais après pareille
nos gouvernants faesch passé du grand
n'importe quoi puisqu'il autorise des
manifestations on peut être entassés
dans des trains des trucs comme ça donc
les banques comprennent pas donc
alors il ya là